We'll now turn our attention to the issue of
extensibility and some of the approaches that have been taken to achieve this
goal. Historically I should mention that there was interest in
extensibility at least as far back as 1981. With a
system that was developed at CMU called the Hydra operating system. The
Hydra operating system provided kernel mechanisms
for resource allocation. The key word is
mechanisms, not policies, just mechanisms for resource
allocation in the kernel. And it had
a way of providing access to resources,
using a capability based approach. The notion
of a capability has a special conotation
in the operating system, literature. And that
is, it is, an entity that can be passed from one to the
other. Cannot be forged. And can verified. All of the things that
you want in order to make sure that. The system integrity is not compromised, as
enshrined in this abstract notion of capability. And as originally envisioned,
capability was a heavyweight mechanism in
terms of implementing it efficiently in
an operating system. And because capability
is a heavyweight mechanism. The hydra operating
system, resource managers were built as
coarse-grained objects, in order to reduce
the border crossing overhead, because border
crossing in the hydra system would mean
that you have to pass capability from one object to another. And validate
the capability for entering a particular object, and so on, and for that
reason, hydra used coarse-grained objects to
implement resource managers. That way, they can
reduce the border crossing overhead. And
implementing resource managers as coarse-grained objects also
means that it limits the opportunities
for customization and extensibility. In other word,
the closer you make these object, the less opportunity you have for customizing
the services. Which is exactly the
strike against, monolithic kernel as well. So,
while in principle, hydra had all
the right ideas of providing minimal mechanisms
in the kernel. And having the resource managers implement policies because the
fundamental mechanism for accessing the resources was through this capability,
which is a heavy weight abstract notion to implement efficiently. In practice,
hydra did not fully achieve its goal of extensibility. One of
the most well-known extensible operating system of the early 90s was the Mach
operating system from CMU. It was microkernel-based, providing very limited
mechanisms in the microkernel. And implementing all the services that you expect
from an operating system as server processes that run as normal,
user level processes above the kernel. And clearly, with this micro kernel based
approach, Mach achieved its goal of
extensibility. So it focused on extensiblity. And
portability. The keyword is portability. And
therein lies the rub. Performance took a
backseat, because Mach was very much focused
on making the operating system portable across
different architectures, in addition to paying
attention to extensibility. And this, unfortunately, gave
a bad press for microkernel based design. Because it focused on these twin
goals of portability and extensibility, allowing
performance to take a backseat. And since
operating systems are generally so focused
on performance. This design choice in Mach
of supporting portability gave microkernel-based design
a bad press. But later on, when
we look at L3 approach to microkernel-based design, we will revisit the right
way to build a microkernel-based design. But in this lesson, let's focus on Spin
Approach to Extensibility. So the key idea in spin is to co-locate
a minimal kernel with its extension in the same hardware address space
and avoid the border crossing between the components of. The kernel and
the extensions of the kernels that are containing the specific services
that the applications need. And this core location, also means that we avoid
the border crossing which he said is one of the biggest potentials for losing
out on performance. But, if you're going to
co-locate the kernel and extensions in the same
hardware address space, isn't that compromising on
protection? Wasn't that the strike against the
DOS-like structure that we talked about earlier?
Well, the approach that Spin took was to
rely on the characteristics of a strongly typed programming language,
so that the compiler can enforce the modularity
that we need in order to give guarantees
about the protection. So, by using a strongly typed
language, in the case of Spin they used modular three more on that in a minute.
The Colonel is able to provide. Well defined interfaces, all of you may be
quite familiar with declaring function prototypes in
a hydra file and having the actual implementation
of the procedures in other files. In a large software project, this is the same
idea that is now taken to the design of the operating system itself. After all,
operating system is also a piece of software,
a complex piece of software, and why not
use a strongly typed language as the basis
for building the operating system. That's the idea in
the spin approach. Now, what you get when
you use a strongly typed language, is that you
cannot cheat. For instance, in a language like
C, you can type cast pointers so that a
given data structure can be viewed
completely differently, depending on what you need
to get done. At the moment. That's not possible with a strongly typed language.
Data abstractions provided by the programming
language such as an object serve as
containers for logical protection domains. That is,
we are no longer reliant on hardware
address spaces to provide the protection between different services.
And the kernel. As I mentioned the kernel provides only the interfaces and these
logical protection domains actually implement the
functionality that is enshrined in those
interface functions. And there can be
several implementations of the interface functions.
And that's where the flexability comes
in. Applications can dynamically bind different
implementations of the same interfaith functions.
And that's how we get different
instanciations of specific system components. Getting
you the flexibility that you want
in constructing an operating system. Because
we have co-located the kernel and the
extension in the same hardware address space, we are making the extensions as
cheap as a procedure call. So in a nutshell, what we've accomplished with
a Spin approach to extensibility as we are writing on
the characteristics of a strongly typed programming language, that
enforces strong typing and therefore allows the operating system
designer to implement logical protection domains instead of relying on hardware
address spaces. And consequently we're making
extensions as cheap as procedure calls.